le monde sait ce courrier est bienvenu à
ce que je t'aime épisode 11
sans commentaire sur le retard c'est
parti jusqu'au fait j'ai pas trop excuse
pas j'avais une idée de fausses excuses
dès qu'il ya des travaux en bas de chez
moi mais je pas sûr que ça aurait pas je
suis sur ta les touches du clavier salle
malpropre alors il n'y a qu'une seule
façon de savoir si ton clavier salses et
de le retourner
s'il ya quelques miettes qui tombent ça
passe s'il ya carrément un goûter qui
tombe ça passe moi squeeze que tu
rejouer la scène que tu préfères dans
son film favori
alors j'ai pas spécialement de films
favoris williams elle que j'ai beaucoup
aimé c'est d'entrer comme quand il a le
filin qui en fait sa fille au téléphone
et qui lui met un petit peu la pression
bon je reproduis la scène si vous ne
vous rendez pas tout de suite je vous
chercherez jeu vous trouverez et je vous
tuerai
spencer pierre blanc film squeeze et
merveilles crédible ça existe oui ça
existe ça suffit j'en ai marre que tout
le monde se moque de moi quand je
m'énerve je suis crédit [ __ ] et voilà
pour ces fous rires à la con que je
rajoute au montage où es tu nous faire
un lieu au beach avec des lunettes de
soleil et une explosion en arrière-plan
bien sûr sauf que ses bayous beach
tennis beach mais bon voilà
l'explosion au l'explosion mais car s'il
te plaît mais qu'est ce qu'il fout quoi
des fois quand tu dis bonjour et que des
gens tous les ponts bonsoir t'attendre
il l'est pas fait alors j'ai pas du tout
envie de baffer par contre je suis mort
de onze qui fait que je panique
légèrement 18h30 et voilà choquant tard
mais par contre quand cette seule et
unique occasion se présente à toi là là
tu te sens bien
bon
chien attention derrière toi mais cette
blague marche plusieurs mois au plus
tard mais je suis mais t'es bête mais je
suis désolé quand même que fais-tu
situant contre miley cyrus
un quart mais ça fait tellement du bien
qu'est-ce que combien d'heures de
nettoyage après ce carnage dodgers
étaient en fait rêver la farine
absolument partout
ah oui non lâche parce que fumer tue en
cas d'invasion de zombies je pense que
je reste sur l'ordi mais au cas où je
m'équipe restore de poids riposter si
jamais ça se passe pas bien
non on n'a pas bon pourquoi tu fais ça
je suis pas il ya plein de boutons
oublie moi j'ai conquis à une invasion
mais non j'ai jamais entendu des bruits
de son média voilà ça tu vois attends tu
es un zombie et non mais ce que j avais
trazom be put ingeus avons rhume des
poids à mes dépends qui vient me tirer
dessus parce que tu as cru que j'avais
raison mais non je ferais tu si tu te
réveiller dans une forêt c'est que tu
devais combattre les indigènes avec mika
et ben vous combattrez alors
probablement les indigènes des cas je
crois comme the forest j'espère pas que
ça se passera comme ça en plus ya pas
trop de médecins sur l'île donc bon on
essaye de faire une pub avec plaisir
découvrez la wii u la nouvelle console
de nintendo
elle recèle de nombreuses options comme
par exemple pèse personne propos
aspirateur sèche-cheveux plateaux-repas
frisbee pour une bonne éclate entre amis
et l'option maracas excusé vos nouvelles
louis matte a acheté la paix maintenant
ah oui aussi j'ai oublié on peut jouer
aux jeux vidéo avec un tu pourrais
refaire la scène du titanic avec talent
page et parfaire le système iq avec ma
lampe alors que la dette
peux-tu faire le ice bogey challen tu
veux dire le ice baguette challenge
c'est une sorte de nouveau challenge
c'est ça pourquoi pas ceci est le ice
baguette charest les nominés sont c'est
lui tu veux les choux marteau et voilà
les gens c'est déjà fort de socoa
jetables épisodes seront j'espère que
vous avez pu si c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas mais la vidéo sa frappe et merci
d'avoir regardé on se retrouve très vite
dans une nouvelle vidéo chère du monde
pis